I don't know. Hi.
So they say that
ghosts
are people caught between two
worlds. I'm caught between two worlds.
I'm an American who passes for a French person. This makes me really rare.
It also means
I don't know if I'm American or French. It also means that fifteen years
ago, I was asked to go to Paris as editor in chief of Paris Vogue.
The first time an American has ever been asked to edit a French publication. And the last
(laughter)
(applause)
I, I wasn't used to working in offices. I hadn't
had a desk job at that point for
years. And so I had to go to Paris and act like a grown up. And I
also needed to work very hard, but worse than that I had to find an apartment
that would be fitting for my station. So I
looked at a lot of apartments, and they were too big or too small or too dingy or too
dark or, all of them, too ordinary. Until one day. I was in
the Rue Jacob.
Every American's favorite Paris street. The Rue Jacob
was picturesque.
It's on the left bank, and it's easy to pronounce - Jacob. And it's full
of antique shops that have very beautiful objects in them. Objects that you would
want to put in your very beautiful apartment on the Rue Jacob, if you could find such a
thing, which I did. Up a stone staircase from the seventeenth
century, the color of honey or freshly baked bread.
Two gigantic lacquered doors opened into a foyer. And there was
a dining room on the right. And then there was a living room:
Eighteen feet wide, eighteen feet long, and eighteen feet high.
A perfect cube.
And next to it was an American kitchen, the realtor said. I was reassured. And there
was a study. There was a long corridor, and at the end of that was a bedroom that
was another perfect cube. All of this perfection covered
in moldings from the late 18th century, 5 minutes before the revolution.
The place was perfect. Also,
fifteen years ago, this perfection, this palace cost only two hundred dollars
more than my rather dingy boring apartment on the Upper East Side.
So I found myself in the office of the pair of rather peculiar
lawyers near the "Place de Peace"?? and they put this piece of paper on the desk.
and they read. They
said,  "Madam, you must hereby attest that
we have informed you on this day that the apartment situated at 11 Rue Jacob...
moves at night.
Please sign here and initial on top." So I sign. I initial.
They also warned me that,
given who I was and what I was doing in Paris, I would certainly be giving parties in this magnificent apartment,
if I could possibly keep the more corpulent guests
around the perimeter because they couldn't really vouch for the safety of the middle of the floor.
So,
the possessor of this very beautiful rental, I move in. I figure out that
I'm going to put the bed on the wall that's between, there's this wall between the study and the bedroom,
I put the bed there. What am I going to do about the very high windows?
Oh! Beige felt curtains.
Felt -- cheap, practical. And all the French people say, "Oh, that is so intelligent. Felt!" And
I give a party and I keep the more corpulent people around the perimeter and there's an exceptionally
fat Italian designer who I keep by the window. I ask him to "please, will you
make sure to tell me who's coming?"
And, these parties are not
really parties, they're work. Everything is work. I'm working twenty hours a day. So that when I come
home to bed, I crash.
I sleep like a dead person. After four months, I realize I don't
have to work twenty hours a day, I can work nineteen hours a day. So I'm beginning to get a bit more normal
and that's when
in the middle of the night, one night, I awaken because
there is a pool on the bed clothes on my left as if
somebody is lying on the covers next to me.
And there's a soft little hand touching my forehead.
And I lie there wondering
if somebody is actually in the room. And with a great act of courage
I put out my arm and I turn on the light and there is no one there.
Now, I'm the Editor in Chief of Paris Vogue. I absolutely refuse to believe that any of this
nonsense is happening. It's ridiculous. However, the next day I
do go around the corner to the church of St. Germain des Pres.
And, I'm
not quite sure how you do these things, but I go into the office and there's a woman there making
notes in a little notebook, and I wait.
And she looks up, she has me for my name. I give a fake name because, you know, I don't want people
to know that I think what I'm about to tell her. And it's not the right kind of name: she looks
at me skeptically. And I say "I live around the
corner, and I think my apartment is maybe haunted. Is there a priest who could come and..."
And the woman,
who's got a greasy bun and greasy glasses looks at me through the
greasy glasses, with
total contempt. And she says, "Madam, that is superstition!"
So I leave the church of St. Germain des Pres, and I know one thing: I'm not going to let a single
person in Paris know that I'm crazy enough to think
that there's something in my bedroom at night. So I go
back. Ha. I give another party. Everybody says it's so
wonderful. And, uh, I don't tell
anyone what happens at night in my room.
And, in fact, I'm really lonely. So, you know, it's
not bad.
(applause. laughter.)
So, one June morning. A cold freezing June
morning, I wake up-- one of those horrible grey
French June mornings -- and I turn on my light and there's no electricity and I think, "Oh my
God, I forgot to pay the bill and they've cut me off." The French, they're always punishing you.
So I go to the office. I get the bill paid. That evening, I have
dinner with friends who are Italian. They're really nice. I've known them
a long time. Maybe I can confide in them. And I do. And the wife says,
"Wait a second. You have no electricity. You have something in your bedroom. And
you're going home tonight and you're going to like, go to your bedroom with
the candle? No no. Come stay with us tonight." I say, "Great. Great. Thank you very much.
Can I please just pack a little bag?" So we go back to my apartment. We put the husband in the living room
with some tequila. And the
wife says, "Let's take a look at this ghost of yours." So I walk down the
long corridor with two votive candles. And I know there's nothing to see because I've never
seen anything.
And we go into the bedroom and I turn to face the bed. And there on the bed I
see the indentation of a body lying there.
At that very moment the wife says, "You know what, I think I'll wait for you in the
living room." So, now
I really don't know what to do because if I ask her if she's seen it, and she hasn't seen it, I'm
nuts. So I just let her
go and I put my candles down, and I pack my little
bag. And the next morning, the bill is paid. The electricity
is put on again. And  that evening, when I come home, the first thing I do: I move that bed from
that weird wall over to the other side of the room, in front of the bricked up fireplace,
underneath the mantelpiece that's made of marble that looks a little bit like a
tombstone. But it's kind of a good place for the bed. And all the
French people come and look at the bedroom and they say, (chuckles) "You know, you really want to sleep there?
Because it looks like a grave!"
And, so I lie. I say
"Oh, I really like it." And they say, "Mmm, it's very punk. Yes."
So, when I'm sleeping over there nothing happens. I'm OK.
And I think about the building. And the people who own the building
have exactly the same apartment above me. Foyer, dining room. The cube
living room. The study.The bedroom.
And, one October night,
I'm woken in the middle of the night by the sound of somebody
in the room above me
being thrown from one end of a wooden floor to the other and hitting the far
wall with a
thud. And then there's a scream. And then there are
blows, and more screams, and wails, and cries, and some kind of snorting sound.
And the sound of the violence
is so loud that my room is moving.
So, I put on some shoes. I put on a coat. I run downstairs to the
courtyard because I want to see what's
happening in that room above my room. And I see my pale
beige felt curtains in my
window. And above, I don't see anything. There's no noise. There's
nothing moving. There's no light. There's no shadows. There's just the October
full moon reflected in the closed windows.
So I go back up to my room. And I do what any American would do: I get out a sage stick from New
Mexico,
and light it. And I get a shell
and I put it on the table next to my bed and I put the sage stick in
the shell because this is going to get rid of whatever's going on.
But, the flames jump up. The
flames multiply. Something in my bedroom is feeding
the sage stick.
And it burns so bright and so hard that it
scorches the table. The next day, I call my neighbors.
My owners.
And I insist on going upstairs for a drink-- I'm going to be really brave-- and I go up, I go up the stairs.
And they offer me a really teeny glass of wine. And they show me their apartment. And it's terribly
neat and rather austere, just like
them. And I say, "So, your apartment is exactly like mine."And they say, "Yes, yes.
But of course we sleep in the dining room." I say, "Oh. Really?
Why don't" ... "Oh, no no no. We never go into the back room. (Chuckles). No. We're
much happier in the dining room."
Ok.  So now I really don't know what to do. Because I'm not going back to the Catholic Church after
they've humiliated me like that. But! I have a tame Tibetan
acupuncturist. I go to Dr Tong ?Lang? and I say,
"Do you ever do any exorcism?"
He says, "Well not personally but I work with Lamas who can
clean various auras in various places just by looking at photographs."
So I go back to my place. I photograph the bedroom. This
was 1997:I take the photos to be developed. You know I don't want anybody
at the magazine to know about this. After the fashion shows the photos are developed. I take them in
to the Tibetan Lama-acupuncturists and he promises that he will get it to the other Lamas.
And I think, "You know, I'm out of my mind. Right?" Then my
father comes to stay. And he thinks the apartment is very beautiful. I
don't discuss anything about what I might suspect. We're
standing outside the apartment, outside the glorious lacquered doors one day,
and he's just standing there stock still. And suddenly,
he's thrown down the
stairs. And I run down. I pick him up--he's actually OK. But
I know that
something from the apartment threw him down the stairs. And that's it. I go
to the Right Bank. I find an apartment. An ordinary nineteenth century apartment
With no drama about it. And everybody in Paris says,
"You're moving to the Right Bank when you have this palace on the Rue Jacob? "
rouge a
And I say, "You know what, I really think the Left Bank is just so over." (laughter).
And
they say, "You're right!" So, one day I'm in the Cafe Fleur-- I
haven't
quite moved yet--and there's a young designer who I
know vaguely who's been to the parties, who comes running up to me and says, "Cherie, you're leaving
that apartment!" And I say, "yes." And he says. "How can you do that?" I say, "Well, you know,
..." And he says, "Tell me something: I would do anything to live in that apartment. Have you
given the lease to someone else? I say, "No." He says, "Is
there someone else living there?" And
I have a moment where I
think, mmm. And then I think he'd tell everybody.
And I know he'd tell everybody.
And he says, " Please, please, please.  I want to live in that apartment. Can I have the lease?"And I say, "Yes."
(laughter)
So, I give him the lease. I move to the Right Bank. I get a boyfriend. I'm no
longer lonely. The magazine begins to
sell incredibly well. I become friends with ?Mark McLaren.?  Everything goes absolutely fabulously.
And, once in a while I go to the Rue Jacob because I would like some antiques to put in
my nineteenth century apartment and sometimes I pass in front of my old place and I
see that there's a scaffolding. I see there are painters doing extraordinary things to it.
Karl Lagerfeld is apparently paying for all the
work. And, I never go up there.
I never run into the young designer anymore. He's nowhere to be seen. Two, three
years later I see him in Milan. And I say, "Hey, you're not in Paris anymore?"
He says, "Well, you know, I
never sleep in Paris. I sleep in Rome. I sleep in Milan. I sleep in Brussels. I sleep
in London. And I'll sleep at the airport." And I say, "Really, how's our apartment?"
He says, "Oh, honey. It's so
haunted."